everyone we're here at Harry Potter land
and it is very very cool and exciting
with me here here we got honeydukes
and let's go check it out what's going
[Music]
[Applause]
whose chocolate frogs
[Music]
this is some sort of Harry Potter ride
yeah there is actually it's really
really cool I gotta show you where it is
and we'll go to Ollivanders next
[Music]
so if we go in there we'll go to
Ollivanders and there they actually
smite select you for a one fitting which
is very very cool and we're going to be
coming up soon to Hogwarts there is
no it's blue I've been on this ride a
few times the first time I actually got
red very teary-eyed because it was
really really special it was very very
cool second time didn't get teary-eyed I
was excited it was coming but it was
just a very epic and I've actually never
this is the one in California so I've
never actually been to the one in
Orlando so I don't know if you guys my
only disappointment is that they don't
have like Snape or Voldemort walking
around and costume or something like
that and they also even got like a
little ride took this
overall it's like such an awesome
experience being here if you guys want
me to check out any of the shops please
let me know in the comments and I'll do
like another live stream and I'm gonna
get to enjoying some of hogs meat as
we're entering it again
[Music]
oh wow thanks for the superjet I don't
know you guys are actually sending
superjet love your vids man what's your
favorite Harry Potter movie hello from
Mexico hello I probably have to see the
Goblet of Fire
because I remember reading that book and
it was like one of my favorites
[Music]
should I get a cloak so I got two passes
to Universal Studios so I can come again
in a couple days go to outpost let's
check it out
[Music]
oh wow
I really want one of those cloaks flips
let me sweeten up what should we check
out next you guys want to see next
sweet rice on the sweets
[Music]
it's too bad we can't all just go into
all the vendors there's a line waiting
let's trigger platform 9 and 3/4
[Music]
you guys if you want to try some of
these
and do a taste test I'm gonna Bertie
Botts every flavor beans
[Music]
go down here
how cool would it be bad like Snape just
like walking around and I wish they had
that they do
let me ask excuse me do you have Snape
walking around anywhere I don't know
no Baltimore
unfortunate he wasn't very in character
it should have been like no they're off
being Death Eaters
what's this job did you already going
here
no I don't think we did
we did we did go in here I'm getting
food but all the wizardry and magic
well guys leave some comments down below
I'm gonna check out some other stuff you
want to do that birdie flavor the the
every flavor beans Bertie Botts every
flavor beans I put on get like a bogey
one but yeah it's pretty cool so let me
know down below
I'll get that follow-up video for you
guys thank you so much for watching I'll
see you all in the next